hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
in front of you are two fair dice
one is a seven sided dice with faces
numbered negative three negative two
negative one zero one two and three
the other is an eleven sided dice with
faces numbered from negative five to
five that is the integers from negative
five to five
you pick a dice and i will get the other
one
we will roll together and the person
with the larger number wins
if the two dice show the same number we
will roll again until someone wins
which dice should you pick if you want
to maximize your chance of winning
now you can also solve this problem for
the generalized case where one dice has
integer sides going from negative n to n
and the other dice has integer sides
going from negative m to m
i want to mention the source i adapted
this problem from a post on puzzling
stack exchange
finally just a little bit of trivia
according to the oxford dictionaries
historically dice is the plural of dye
but in modern standard english dice is
both the singular and the plural
throw the dice could mean a reference to
either one or more than one dice
so can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so we'll get started by writing the
sample space
the seven-sided dice could show any of
the following seven numbers
the 11-sided dice can show any of the
following 11 numbers and these will be
with equal chance
so we have a total of 7 times 11 which
equals 77 equally likely possibilities
now of these
seven possibilities will be ties in
which the game is a draw so we're going
to exclude this because the game does
not end on these you in fact roll again
this leaves 70 game ending rolls
now imagine the seven sided dice rolls a
1 and the 11 sided dice rolls a negative
4. one is larger than negative four so
this will be a win for the seven sided
dice
in fact
all of these outcomes to the left of
this diagonal will be a win for the
seven-sided
dice this is a total of 35 game-winning
outcomes for the seven-sided dice
all of the possibilities to the right of
the diagonal will be wins for the
11-sided dice and this will be a total
of 35 game-winning outcomes for the
11-sided dice
so
we'll put this together
the probability that 7 wins will be its
35 game-winning outcomes divided by the
70 outcomes in which the game ends and
that's exactly the same as the
probability that the 11 sided dice wins
and 35 over 70 is equal to 50 percent
so the two are equal to each other
each dice has an equal chance of winning
furthermore this is true in the general
case as well
we can imagine the same sort of table
where we have the roles of the n dice
and the roles of the m dice
now if n is less than m there will be n
possibilities in which the two roles are
equal and these will be re-rolls and
will exclude these possibilities
every outcome to the left of this
diagonal will be a game-winning outcome
for the end dice and every outcome to
the right of this diagonal will be a
game-winning outcome for the m dice
in fact there will be a one-to-one
correspondence between these outcomes
in the general case the end dice wins
for all pairs i comma j such that i is
greater than j
but for every such pair there is an
outcome negative i comma negative j
which must be a win for the m dice this
is because negative j will be greater
than negative i
similarly every winning outcome for the
m dice can be paired with a win for the
n dice by the same mapping where i comma
j goes to negative i comma negative j
hence there is a bijection between the
winning outcomes for each dice so each
dice must have the same 50 chance of
winning the game is fair in the general
case
did you figure it out
thanks for watching these math videos
which can be watched for free on youtube
inspire and build confidence for people
around the world and they have over a
hundred million views please subscribe
for free to get the news videos and
email me a puzzle or math topic presh
and mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise which is listed on teespring
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support